please welcome Sebastian Maniscalco born
and raised in the Chicago area and here
he is making a dramatic entrance here on
the Dan Patrick show is it is it tough
to do comedy early in the morning
Sebastian I don't know no it's not no I
I'm ready to go I'm ready to go
everybody's got a laptop I feel out of
place you want to laugh well I can get
you a laptop I don't know what you're
gonna do with it I I noticed in the book
though there's a picture of you and you
used to do Michael Jackson at birthday
parties started doing it fifth grade at
the ice cream social and I won the you
know it's like a talent show and then I
started doing it people started asking
me you want to do this at my birthday
party
so I would go to the birthday parties
and then I would slip into the bathroom
change into the Michael Jackson outfit
and then I would come out in their
living room and no one knew this was
happening like that everybody's like
having fun at the party and all of a
sudden Billie Jean starts and I come out
of the bathroom and be like what's going
on and I would do a Billie Jean and beat
it for for about ten minutes you just
dance just right in the living room
that's weird yeah they just wanted me to
you know kind of you know they would
give me some food or what-have-you but I
was like in the neighborhood I was known
as the guy who always did the Michael
Jackson impersonation okay but when did
you know that you could tell jokes oh
you could do this for a living
I knew young that I was gonna do
stand-up I told my second-grade teacher
I was gonna do stand-up comedy for a
living when they went around for a
career day I said I wanted to be a
stand-up I always fell in love but that
was from the like Johnny Carson that's
all I used to watch I used to watch
Three's Company John Ritter was a big
influence on me with the physical comedy
and all that stuff so I used to immerse
myself in stand-up comedy but when you
look at these guys then you're trying to
figure out who can I be like because you
can watch people and go I can't do that
but I want to do it but I can't do it
like that person does who did I want to
be like did anybody intimidate you where
you go oh my like that's different I
can't do that no no I mean I just I
watched all styles of comedy and and
knew I was going to be able to do it I
was never the class clown I was always
kind of the observer we sat back and
looked at people and and kind of had my
internal dialogue going like I looked at
the class clown I'm like sit down not
funny you know I always thought the
class clown wasn't funny
so yeah I was the class clown oh you
were yeah I wasn't funny I was best
dressed that was my claim to fame okay
would you rather be class clown or best
dressed
well you burn rather be best dressed I
actually was trying to get Best Dressed
oh you were yeah oh man I had no shot
with that no no I had hand-me-downs from
a brother a brother who was five inches
shorter and about 20 pounds less than me
but those were the clothes that I got
because he was two years older than me
all right it's pretty tough to make an
impression chance yeah no chances but
when you get to LA and you're trying to
do this you go to the comedy store did
you end up there yes in 1998 I got into
Los Angeles I went to the comedy store
because I thought that was the mecca of
comedy in Los Angeles and you know I got
in there and I'm open mic night Mitzi
shore had asked me to prepare a I think
it was a six minute set at this at the
time and then asked me back to do a
10-minute set and got in really early
there like early ninety nine I got it
who was hanging out there at the time
you remember God it was slim pickins
there at the time it's not the way it
was now back then you know I remember
watching Eddie Griffin come in there
Dice Clay used to come in there a lot
but it was just it wasn't as popular as
it was now I mean it had its heyday in
the 80s but the time I got there in 1998
it wasn't wasn't one of the best comedy
clubs going are you an athlete were you
an athlete growing up played soccer
all-conference of course in high school
obviously but I played I played
basketball freshman beat bench never
played organized football but yeah I was
athletic now I not so much right now my
favorite game I just picked this up by
the way guys
pickleball it's good workout good
workout good exercise that's about all I
could do as far as I and all ages can
play pickleball all ages it's mainly
senior citizens but you know I've picked
it up you want to explain pickleball
pickleball is like badminton tennis and
like ping pong almost combined into one
game it's a smaller court than a tennis
court he played with a paddle and a
wiffle ball yeah yeah I've seen it you
know yeah McLovin have you seen
pickleball I haven't heard of it what is
it is it a called paddle ball on a small
court what's the difference I don't know
what paddle ball is I'm just getting
into the just maybe I'll graduate a
paddle ball
maybe paddle ball comes after pickleball
but yeah I just started playing recently
and I find it very very fun and get a
nice little cardiovascular exercise you
have a bit where you talk about Italians
don't play basketball
yeah we don't why it's just not
something that a lot of Italians get
into I just don't think the Italians are
abundant in the in the basketball realm
of things but short you know the the
just it's not really promoted in the
Italian culture it's not like you know
you're sitting around and you know your
uncle Luigi says you should be a better
how do you do humor so you make fun of
the Italians but how does that go over
with the Italians when you make fun I
make fun it's more like I I make fun of
the upbringing I had and my father and
the kind of old-school
of raising kids my father came here from
Sicily when he was 15 years old and and
the stuff I talked about kind of
resonates with the Italian culture I
mean you don't have to be Italian to get
it but if you have like an overbearing
father or a father who's constantly on
your back that's kind of how I grew up
he still is you know he still comes to
my shows he's taking notes in the back
with a with a notepad and then it'll
come in afterwards and and and and you
know he was what happened with the
subway bit you know it's like it's like
a it's like a like if you were going a
little league and then you know you had
a bad game on the way home your father
is like you know you got to get down and
get the ball that's the way he is
looking at my comedy career and he's the
one that will be honest with you oh yeah
you know I'll do this show right and
then he'll watch it and then and then if
I if he doesn't call me that means I did
bad oh yeah okay like everything's
critiqued just like I'm looking right
now my mother will probably call me go
put tuck his shirt down when you do
these you know like it's constant its
constant critiquing in my family would
you give your expert opinion on this is
fritzy's
last joke that he had last night at the
Comedy Store
all right so let's play it here so
fritzy last night went to Israel anybody
had been to Israel Tel Aviv Jerusalem
and all that so my biggest concern even
though I wanted to see cabooses and try
shwarma and some of the weird
Mediterranean food was to make sure we
had two separate rooms so the wife and I
got free but we have a little intimacy
it'd be nice so I spent the extra money
to rooms one for the kids and one for my
wife and I nothing so I don't know what
move is exactly but she's like what are
you doing what do you know in the whole
surprise I know it's it's waiting for
the joke table out it's it's it's it's
so good it's it's there's one joke in
there but if I could give a critique and
listen I know you've been doing this you
know this is the third time it takes a
while to do this and it's it's what I
had the problem with in the beginning is
too many words you know to get to the to
the joke you got to cut the fat off the
you know there's a lot of explaining
that you don't really need to do in
there and that just comes with time and
repetition and whatnot I mean that's
that's just it's like anything else you
don't you don't know how to catch a
football when the first time you run out
and do a pattern you know I'm saying
it's just multiple times but I think you
did I like I like comedy coming from a
real place and then and that that's
coming from a real place I will say and
then not to uh not that you need my pat
on the back but when I went to see you a
few weeks ago at Mohegan Sun in
Connecticut you know I was just in awe
when I when you see it someone doing
stand-up and I just did that five
minutes when you have a material and you
can do for like an hour and a half two
hours in a sold-out arena and people of
all ages and and religions and cultures
all find find it hysterically funny I
don't know what's more amazing and why
don't why don't you trim the fat on the
compliment there I probably could have
tightened like this and so many people
want to come to is just doing the same
thing like trying to fat that's very
sweet of you to say it's an awesome
thing to be able to do and to do it well
and have that much material you can go
on this is the third
listen to be at the Comedy Store on your
third time no that's that's cuz he
called it a favor I we never did call me
oh is that right yeah that's how you got
on
yeah well still I mean to be on the
comedy store stage and that's the
original room yeah yeah yeah so and I
know business big up there but because
Dad and the Sandman are our buddies they
uh you know we're able to make that work
yeah you gotta take advantage of your
connections here and then you got
Madison Square Garden sold-out yeah we
have through four shows there too last
show still tickets available January
19th and 20th and yeah the New York area
has been really really good to me over
the years and we decided to do the
garden and at first were like yeah I
think we maybe could do two shows but we
got the we got four I don't know they
can you have too big of an audience like
these these arenas are very large I do
it in the round I try to make it as
intimate as I possibly can there's like
a screen above my head where you know
people that are sitting in the upper
deck could kind of be a part of the show
yeah but comedy is meant to be enjoyed
just like you just saw there in a small
comedy club you know but you know it's
just I'd have to I'd have to do a lot of
comedy club shows Sebastian Maniscalco
and fritzy really thinks a lot of his
stand-up act I got a chance to meet him
before he was kind of to meet me before
the show and my book is called stay
hungry times bestseller it's a national
bestseller like you went past the New
York Times you know if you don't get the
New York Times then you know you don't
you don't care at the end of the world
no this is Nationals is still national
yeah and you're gonna be in the movie
Green Book yeah you're in the movie yeah
it's a really good movie yeah got some
great reviews so far yeah I think this
is gonna be a real big hit yeah and you
may turn into Adam Sandler where you
just leave stand up and start doing
movies I will always do stand-up comedy
these movies are nice don't get me wrong
but stand up you can't Apple Sandler
just went back on did a special you know
where he went back on tour Jerry
Seinfeld like it never leaves you guys
no Jay Leno still does this knows you
can't you can't it's it once it's in you
it's in you you got to keep doing it for
it to use it in you to do what that's
great timing right there even though you
weren't trying to be funny that was
funny
accidental humor there well done hey
maybe during the commercial break you
can tell me what you think of Sebastian
Maniscalco okay
Sebastian thanks for coming in good luck
with the book and B book and the green
book stay hungry is the name of the book
and go to sebastian live.com for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]